Stop searching for that
perfect blanket pattern.
Why not create your own?
Learn how to plan, size,
and customize a blanket on your knitting
machine using Knit It Now tools.
No guesswork, just creativity.
The first thing to think about is size.
Unlike hand knitting, your knitting
machine has a limited number of needles.
We can't just pick up a larger hand
knitting needle and cast on more stitches.
So how do you knit something larger
than your machine's needle bed?
There's a few options.
Number one, knit your blanket
in panels and seam them together.
This is great for simple patterns
and lets you mix and match colors easily.
Option number 2, no sew join techniques.
Want to avoid sewing?
Use a sew as you go join.
Techniques like hairpin lace seams
or a slip stitch crochet can
help you create a seamless look.
Option number 3, modular knitting.
You can also build your blanket one
square or one rectangle at a time.
Maybe even put some triangles together.
Think of it like a quilt
but made with yarn.
Next, let's talk yarn.
Now, you don't want to be playing yarn
chicken and run out part of the way
through your project, right?
Here's how to estimate
how much you'll need.
Knit, measure, and weigh a swatch.
The best way to calculate
yardage is by making a swatch.
Measure your gage and then multiply
the total area of your blanket.
Also, factor in the stitch pattern.
Now, some stitches,
like tuck or slip stitch,
use more yarn than plain old stockinette.
If you're using some textures or cables,
plan for even more extra yardage.
Yarns are made for the yarn weight.
Remember that the yarn weight matters.
Thicker yarns, like
those you would use on a bulky machine,
they knit up faster,
but they use more yardage.
Lighter yarns on a standard gage machine
may take longer to knit, but they'll
give you more drape and softness.
Find a yarn you love and look
for blanket patterns using that yarn.
That's the best way to gage
how much yarn you'll need.
Now for the fun part,
choosing your stitch pattern.
The right stitch pattern can add warmth,
texture, color, and even
bold designs to your blanket.
Think in terms of simple textures.
Tuck and slip stitch makes your blanket
extra cozy without adding
a whole lot of bulk.
It's perfect for baby blankets.
If you want to do color work like
fair-isle, remember Fair-Ele can create
long floats in the back of the fabric.
Lining your blanket with fleece or another
layer of knitting not only will enclosed
those floats, but it will
make an extra warm blanket.
Want a blanket that looks
great on both sides?
Dust off your ribber and try double bed
knitting for a fully reversible design.
And there you have it.
By planning your size,
calculating your yarn,
and choosing the right stitch,
you can create beautiful machine
knit blankets with confidence.
If you found this video helpful,
check out the blanket classroom at Knit
It Now for even more tips and tutorials.
We do a deep dive into planning,
designing, and knitting blankets.
Our DIY blanket pattern is a no-brainer,
no-math blueprint for your creativity.
Happy knitting, and we'll
see you in the next video..